the Anaconda is the world's largest
snake and among the most deadly an
anaconda can swallow hold an animal the
size of an average dog
it kills by wrapping itself around its
prey tightening its grip till its victim
can no longer breathe herpetologist
paces rebus studies these fearsome
creatures for a living most of the time
he manages to escape their wrath but
today his luck runs out
unable to escape the anaconda Strikes
Back it sinks its fangs deep into a
Seuss's flesh his survival depends on
extricate in his hand what would you do
in this situation should you pull your
hands straight out of the snake's mouth
push your hand further down the snakes
throat or put the snake in the eyes the
answer is B push your hand further down
the snakes throat toukiden in the eyes
won't it let go more likely a good poke
will only make it dive into the water
taking you with it pulling your hands
straight out of the snake's mouth
actually pushes the teeth deeper into
the flesh
that's because anacondas teeth bend
backwards
to safely extract yourself from the
Anaconda you have to actually push
deeper into the mountain and off the
teeth and that's how you survive an
anaconda bite